well as you can see if you're watching
this on video I'm starting to wear my
Christmas colors you know it's a day
before Thanksgiving so I figure I'm kind
of late in starting to celebrate
Christmas and can I just say that this
is one thing I don't understand that
every year people complain about how
well people are celebrating Christmas
too early and then you're putting up the
Christmas lights too early before
Thanksgiving I don't understand
complaining about that and I and I say
that as someone who complains about
about everything I can complain I could
find a reason to complain about almost
anything there could be a leprechaun
could ride in on a unicorn right now and
give me a pot of gold and I could think
of a reason to whine about it but even I
can't think of a reason to complain
about people about Christmas music in
November or whatever are people putting
up Christmas lights early what why it's
it's it's a happy wonderous thing why
why be angry about it have you ever been
driving in a car with someone at night
in like early November and you go buy a
house and there's Christmas decorations
up and they get really mad about it
they're like this is outrageous what do
they look at this it's November 2nd
they've got Christmas lights up why do
they have Christmas lights up calm down
it's just it's they're just colorful
lights on someone's bush that you that's
what you're mad about right now why
would that make you mad I don't get it
so I welcome I welcome the intrusion of
Christmas into you know the how
Christmas has bleeding out and taking
over more and more of the year I welcome
it I think it's I think it's a wonderful
thing all right
but speaking of Thanksgiving a few
things about Thanksgiving I want to I
want to talk about let me start with
that with the most the most important
thing as you prepare your Thanksgiving
meals just one one thing I want to tell
you this is the correct Thanksgiving
meal okay and it's important for you to
understand this all other Thanksgiving
meals are incorrect this is what the
correct meal is turkey gravy stuffing
green bean casserole cranberry sauce
mashed potatoes sweet potatoes
a second green vegetable now this can be
asparagus broccoli or Brussels sprouts
not all three you choose one bread rolls
pumpkin pie real whipped cream beer red
wine and then either scotch bourbon or
rye whiskey if you want to do all three
of the brown liquors you can but you
certainly need one of them anyone who
puts a seafood dish on the table for
Thanksgiving has committed a felony
salad is a superfluous ridiculous thing
to put on the table it's completely
redundant we've already got the
vegetables covered you don't you that's
just filler you don't need salad more
than two green vegetables is unnecessary
and frankly kind of disturbing so if
you're going to pad things out and add
more dishes
the additional dishes should involve
meat in some capacity
now deviled eggs are not really a
traditional Thanksgiving thing but I
will allow that I'll allow you to have
that on Thanksgiving well here's one
other note really important but a lot of
people don't understand apparently gravy
is the most important item on the things
it's more important than the turkey
because the meal will rise or fall with
the quality of the gravy the gravy is
essential people who don't like gravy
are not real Americans they're not even
human I don't think and anybody who
hosts a Thanksgiving dinner and does not
provide gravy is a dangerous sociopath
I was another I'm not making this up I
once if you can believe it I once
attended a Thanksgiving dinner where
there was no gravy and then I said oh
there's no gravy on the tip you want to
go grab the gravy so maybe it's still on
the stove I'll go grab the gravy for you
and I was told oh no no we don't have
any gravy and so I I ran from the table
crying and I locked myself in the
bathroom and wept for the rest of the
night as any man would do in that
situation I just think all these points
are important because because people
these days they're far too eager to get
cute and clever on Thanksgiving you know
they try to get away from the staples
and sometimes you'll see these articles
online people share on Facebook or
whatever about well here are some
creative things you can do for your
Thanksgiving meal
no no nothing creative see some things
should not be tampered with it some
things are just perfect as their it
reminds me of the time where I was at
someone's house and they served brownies
and I bit into the brownie and then only
the
did I just discover that they had put
raisins in the brownies and then the
person said oh I thought I'd do
something a little bit different with
the brownies something a little
different why they're brownies they're
perfect any amount of different is a
deviation from perfect you could only go
down from perfect so whatever you're
doing it's going to be less than perfect
you can't improve perfect don't try just
make the brownies stop being selfish
stop trying to make it about yourself
this is what I said to them I was never
invited back I just the point is the
same philosophy applies to the
Thanksgiving dinner so stick to the
staples and and focus on those don't get
creative and everybody will have a
blessed and wonderful Thanksgiving all
right another point about selectivity
around this time every year we are we
are treated to news articles explaining
how we should deal with our racist
conservative relatives at Thanksgiving
you know you see these these articles
every single year and this year is no
exception the New York Times published
an article explaining how to have
conversations with your relatives and
they even gave a script they gave you a
script of how they imagined this
conversation should go so here's just
that here's a sample of the script okay
in the New York Times conservative uncle
Trump has been great for America just
look at the economy it's booming you so
how are you doing financially
conservative uncle how am i doing not
that great actually but things that
would have been worse under Hillary you
what are your biggest economic hurdles
right now conservative uncle my biggest
hurdles well no matter how hard I work I
can't get ahead I'm living paycheck to
paycheck you so you feel pretty insecure
money-wise despite how hard you're
working
conservative uncle yeah I do feel
insecure money-wise and I don't know how
long I can keep up and then just goes on
and then eventually the conservative
uncle realizes that oh yeah you know
what maybe Trump actually is terrible
because I'm not doing well financially
now I have no idea why the New York
Times is literally giving us a script of
a fake conversation we're supposed to
have with our
huncles but there it is
meanwhile the website eater eater which
is supposed to be a site about food I
assume published an article with this
title the title is you are morally
obligated to call out your racist
relatives at Thanksgiving so here's a
sample of that article says if you can
safely do so read you do not fear
physical or economic reprisal ie getting
kicked out of your house for speaking up
against bigotry you have an obligation
to push back against harmful rhetoric
simply because others do not it is
statistically very likely that a
survivor of abuse or a person who could
face anti LGBT abuse from from your
family will be sitting at your
Thanksgiving table and they may not feel
safe enough to speak against the use of
violent language and homophobic slurs
even if they're hurled by well-meaning
family members first of all what so even
if a well-meaning family member is
hurling violent and homophobic language
what what does that look like exactly
and what kind of dinner table
conversation is this person imagining
the most of us have at our at our during
Thanksgiving just just a bunch of
well-meaning bigots hurling homophobic
and violent language that's all it says
which means that if the only thing
you've got to fear is an awkward silence
as grandma cuts the turkey you've got an
obligation to let your relatives know
that words and actions that the mean the
humanity of others are not acceptable in
your presence
it is highly light unlikely that
anything said across the dinner table is
going to cause some kind of epiphany in
the average bigoted person's mind but
that's that's not the ultimate goal of
speaking out so you know I for one am
going to take this advice and what I sit
down and for Thanksgiving meal the first
thing I'm going to say is I will not
tolerate bigoted or homophobic language
at this table that's the first thing I'm
going to say just to kind of kick off
just as an icebreaker to kick off the
conversation
now there are a couple things to jump
out at me about this kind of stuff
first of all course you have this absurd
paternalism that's very common among
leftist where they think we need
instructions on how to have
conversations with our loved ones
now I mean I know that I just started
this show by giving you instructions on
how to prepare your Thanksgiving meal
but that's different
okay that's different that was okay this
is worse but the second thing is and
this is the more frustrating thing in my
view you see how people are so worried
about the potential of having serious
and substantive conversations with their
families like people think they need to
apparently prepare they need to practice
they need to rehearse before they have a
substantive conversation about politics
or whatever with their families I don't
understand this attitude and I don't
understand and I've never understood the
people who say hey you know the two
things you should never talk about when
you're in a group or you're with your
family are politics and religion never
talk about that what the two things you
should never talk about those are
basically the only things I care to talk
about politics and religion and you can
throw sports in as well so those are the
those are the big three
well what why wouldn't we talk about
them what a boring life people must lead
if they have this policy of never
talking about the most interesting
topics I don't get it
if you dispense with the interesting
topics any topic that might create a
disagreement and thus an actual
discussion because that that's that's
the nature of a discussion is that the
people involved have different
perspectives if everybody has the same
perspective then there's no discussion
there's nothing to talk about if
everyone just agrees on everything what
do you what what's the conversation then
you're all just taking turns saying
things that everyone else can say yep I
agree oh now it's my turn here's my
opinion yep we all agree with that too
it is that is that what how a
conversation supposed to work
no I'll tell you what you're left with
if you if you if you get rid of politics
and religion in any kind of discussion
of an issue that might involve
disagreement you're left with banal
awful pointless small talk you're left
with one of those terrible conversations
where someone shares a boring personal
anecdote and then someone else shares a
similar anecdote and then we just go
around the table and everyone waits
their turn to bore everybody else with
an anecdote you know one of those
conversations where no one is it's not a
conversation everyone's waiting for
their turn to just talk no matter no
matter what they're they happen to be
saying so you're left with that or
you're left with gossip or you're left
with me what else is there I was I was
recently I recently found myself sitting
in a group of people where the
conversation developed into people
taking turns talking about their health
problems and I just thought what why are
we doing this what is what is happening
right now what's the point of that why
are we what kind of conversation is this
or another recent thing I was in is
people are taking turns complaining
about complaining about bad service that
they had gotten in restaurants and
everyone had a story about the bad
service I just don't I don't see the
point then see it might surprise you to
learn that in my personal life I I am
sometimes accused of being quiet but I'm
not as you can tell I just have
absolutely no interest in the dry
pointless babbling small talk that a lot
of people fill their days with and a lot
of people think is that's all you're
supposed to do when you're in a group is
have those kinds of conversations and if
I'm in a group of people and I find the
conversation to be boring and pointless
and stupid I just I'm not gonna say
anything I'm not gonna contribute why
because I
thing to say about the topic because I
think the topic is lame that's all so
when someone says well why aren't you
talking I'm not talking because I you
guys you guys are boring me to death I
just think this is a stupid conversation
but I don't want to say that so I'm just
not gonna say anything now if we could
circle back to something something more
interesting something with a little more
meat to it then you wouldn't be able to
shut me up so I just I don't understand
this reluctance people have to talk
about interesting things we should talk
about them these are the important
things these are the things that define
us I mean think about it when someone
says don't talk about politics don't
talk about religion what they're really
saying is never discuss your most
precious convictions and your most
deeply held beliefs never discuss the
ideas that you organize your life around
well why why shouldn't we just talk
about that that's that that's exactly
what we should talk about I want to talk
about that and not just because I want
to share my own beliefs and and and
convictions I also want to hear other
people share their is that that's how
you really get to know somebody I don't
think you get to know someone through
small talk you get to know someone when
they're telling you what they believe
what their real convictions and
priorities are and and that's how you
get to know somebody and so that's why
I'd rather talk about that
so I wouldn't not that anyone needs
instructions on how to have
conversations at the dinner table but I
would encourage everyone to have forget
about small talk have big talk talk
about big things important things and
then you can really get to it we could
really get to know each other a couple
other things I wanted to touch on
quickly
here's a here's a interesting case a man
is suing British Airways for for sitting
him next to an obese passenger the
passenger said I sat with his knees
wedged against the seat in front and the
rest of his body was over spilling into
my seat by some inches I was immediately
aware that this was going to be
problematic from
and I could feel the weight of his pure
bulk putting lateral pressure on my
upper body and he says he suffered
long-term injuries after undergoing this
for for the whole 12-hour flight which I
mean a 12-hour flight in itself sounds
miserable but to do it when you don't
have a lot of room I can see I hard for
me to believe you would have long-term
injuries but I can see how that would be
extremely uncomfortable now just wanna
make a few points about this about this
issue of obese people on airplanes first
of all people can be very cruel about
this and it seems like a lot of people
have no problem openly complaining about
the obese on airplanes they have no
problem mocking and ridiculing I've seen
people on Twitter tweeting complaints
about the large person sitting next to
them on an airplane while that person is
currently sitting next to them it's it's
very it's very cruel as I said obviously
someone who is who is that big and is
sitting on an airplane seat that they're
already self-conscious about it they
they they're aware of how big they are
they feel embarrassed they feel nervous
I don't know how you could have been
anything but compassion and pity for
someone in that situation I was um I was
one sitting next to someone who it was a
larger person and they had to ask for a
seatbelt extender which I didn't even
know I didn't even know that was a thing
but they you know the seatbelt wasn't
large enough so they had to ask the
flight attendant for a seatbelt extender
and they're obviously embarrassed asking
for it but there was no way for I was
sitting in the middle and they were so
there was no way for them to ask for
without me hearing and I just felt
really bad for this person I and I can't
imagine being angry at them I could tell
they were embarrassed and ashamed and
that's a sad thing I felt I felt bad for
them so I think this is something where
people just need to be human you just
need to be a human bit big people are no
they're big they know how you feel about
sitting next to them on an airplane you
don't need to go advertising you don't
to complain about it openly maybe have a
little bit of human decency instead and
you know I'm not obese but I've been in
situations where I've been I've been on
an airplane and I've been the parent
with a screaming child on a plane which
is the other kind of person that
everyone complains about in airplanes
and again when you're a parent with a
screaming child on a plane trust me
you're you're aware of the fact you know
how everybody feels about you
you know how annoyed everyone is and you
are yourself way more uncomfortable way
more distressed way more disturbed and
way more annoyed than everybody else on
the plane combined so you it's it's it's
not like you're oblivious to it you know
how annoying it is for everyone you know
how disruptive it is the last thing you
need is glaring eyes and rolling eyes
and rude comments and all that kind of
you don't need that there's no reason
for that because you already know so if
you're on an airplane and and there's a
crying child behind you here's what you
don't need to do you don't need to do
that thing where you look back and you
give eyes to the parents why are you
doing the parent knows that the child's
crying thank you very much for the look
it's not necessary the parent knows that
and is very uncomfortable with it but
when a child is intent on crying there's
not always a way to stop them and if
you're on an airplane 30,000 feet in the
air it's not like you can leave so
you're stuck it's I don't know if you
know this maybe some people don't have
kids don't realize it but there is no
switch it's not like there's a switch on
the child's back or something where you
flip the switch and then they stop
crying that doesn't exist the child is a
is a person with a with a brain and so
you can't it's if they just are gonna do
this they're you could try to calm them
down you could try to bribe them you
could try many different things but if
that none of that works you're stuck so
a little bit of a little bit of kindness
and understanding from the fellow
passengers I think that's what's in
order because there's nothing the parent
can do about it if the kid is determined
to cry just like there's nothing an
obese passenger can do in that moment to
change the size of their body frame it
is what it is so you're just so
you know we we just have to all be human
beings and and kind of work together in
that situation now on the other hand and
the reason why this story jumped out of
me because the article about on the
daily wire the article about this
the airline lawsuit has a quote from
Peggy Howell who is the spokeswoman for
the national association to advance fat
acceptance NAFA and she of course blamed
the airlines and said it's their fault
for not having larger seats which she's
not wrong about that by the way airlines
have been consistently shrinking their
seats and their legroom so that now
unless you're underweight and under
sized you can't fit comfortably I'm you
know six feet tall a little bit more
than six feet tall I can't fit in an
airline seat anymore
but the existence of something called
the national association to advance fat
acceptance is a sad statement as well
because it just shows how you have these
two extremes in our culture and on one
extreme you have cruel people people who
mock and ridicule and are very selfish
and on the other extreme you have this
idea that we should accept and celebrate
everything about ourselves we should
celebrate even even the flaws you know
obesity is a flaw in the sense that it's
unhealthy a morbidly obese person is
hurting himself the condition will very
likely kill him eventually it is an
objectively negative condition to be in
if the tracks from health and quality of
life and well-being so acceptance is not
the way to go either
isn't there a happy compromise between
abject ridicule and full-on acceptance
why can't we seek self-improvement and
encourage others in that direction
without mocking and belittling I think
that's the strategy we should take here
rather than this constant back and forth
of these of these of these two extremes
I understand yeah I you know things like
fat acceptance and you know these body
positivity movements I understand why
they exist
because people who are overweight really
do you know they they are ridiculed and
mocked and and and you know their whole
lives and it's a it's a it's a terrible
thing I can't imagine having to endure
that but the answer is not and I think
this is what we tend to do or if we're
you know if if there's something about
us that is as I said objectively not
ideal yet it is also changeable and then
people make fun of us for it and they're
very rude to us and mean to us about it
then we'll tend to kind of go into a
shell and we get on the defensive and we
say well no now now I'm now I'm not
going to change it at a principle I
don't think that's the right move either
we can seek to improve ourselves and
that doesn't mean that we're caving into
the bullying or allowing other people to
control us it's it's all about
respecting ourselves and wanting to be
as healthy as we can and to live as long
as we can alright one last story in
American tourists some reports call him
a missionary I'm not sure if that's true
or not but he has been killed after
attempting to meet and make contact with
a nun contacted tribe on an island off
the the coast of India the Sentinelese
which is a tribe that's protected by law
from outside contact they you know
they're on this island and this man
decided that he wanted to go even though
it's illegal he decided that he wanted
to go and make contact with this with
this tribe so as soon as he he went up
on the canoe and apparently as soon as
he got up on onshore they started
shooting arrows at him but he didn't
turn around he kept walking towards them
and then they ran in and put a rope
around his neck and strangle him to
death so a rather a rather unseemly way
of greeting a stranger but I have to say
this whole uncontacted
thing and you know you have this across
the world in India as well as South
America other places where these there
are these tribes that are living
basically in the year 1000 BC while
governments forbid anyone from going
there and saying hey by the way modern
society is happening out there now I get
that there is a concern about these
people being exploited by outsiders and
there's a very legitimate concern about
disease because they don't have the
immune system built up to deal with all
the nasty modern germs that we carry
around but I've still always found it to
be super weird that we're kind of
preserving them almost like they're a
museum exhibit and or there or there
they're animals in a zoo or something
we're preserving them in what we
consider to be their natural habitat
we're preserving them in a time capsule
and not letting them know that hey by
the way we've got air conditioning out
there and we've got cars and medicine
and the internet in the world don't you
think they have a right to know isn't it
quite possible that they'd prefer to
live like the rest of us if they knew
about it all these people say well you
can't contact the tribes would any one
of them want to live like that would you
like to go live in a mud hut would you
like to go and die from diseases that we
can cure with antibiotics would you like
to go and and you know have your teeth
rotting out of your head it would anyone
want to live that way no that's that's
it that's an objectively miserable way
of living why nobody would want to live
that way it is a rough and and miserable
existence if I was there I would prefer
not to be I'd want to know I'd prefer to
live in modern society so shouldn't they
have that option it's just it's just the
weirdest thing to me now I know that as
I said when you've got these tribes it's
it's not like you can just open the
floodgates and have all these tourists
rush in and all that kind of stuff I'm
not saying that but there should I would
think there should be a concerted
systematic gradual effort may
to introduce these people to
civilization and to let them know about
what's going on out there and then at
least give them that you know if they
decide they want to still live in the
mud huts and die of diseases that they
could cure by taking a pill for a few
days if they prefer that then they have
every right to but I think that they
have a right that they also have the
right to make that choice and so do
their children by the way it's just I
think this stems from this kind of
idolizing we do of indigenous cultures
and indigenous tribes and it's it's
really kind of ridiculous because this
is now I'm I'm the fry I'm a critic of
modern society for a lot of reasons but
even I would say that if I had the
option to go live in the Middle Ages or
to go live in in in the year 400 BC I
would definitely not do it I still
prefer to be here I think there are a
lot of legitimate criticisms to make of
our society but I I like a lot of the
stuff that we have going for us and and
you know I'm a fan of electricity for
instance and I'd prefer to have it
that's it's it's a good thing to have
can you imagine how they wouldn't you be
upset when you be really annoyed and
upset if you were in one of these tribes
and then eventually somehow you found
out about modern society and let's say
you've been living in this tribe for 60
years and nobody ever told you will you
be annoyed about that would you say why
do you guys have to tell me you're
telling me you like you left me there
for 60 years you never told me that this
was happening you were enjoying your air
conditioning you never even told me
about it I'd be upset personally so I
think a gradual integration maybe would
be would be an order and but until that
happens I think it's probably not a
smart idea to go by yourself to one of
these tribes and try to say hello as
unfortunately this American found out
the hard way all right that's it for the
week for me I hope you guys all have a
a wonderful Thanksgiving and I'll tech
to talk to you next week
Godspeed